Hi, I’m John Green,
author, vlog brother, and whatever the
opposite of a mosquito enthusiast is.
You never want to get up close
and personal with mosquitos…
unless it’s like this, a
microscope’s distance away.
Under the lens, the mosquito
undergoes a transformation of sorts.
Before, it was a pesky, biting insect whose
presence was felt at best through the itchy
bumps left on our skin, and at worst
through a whole slew of diseases.
But under the microscope, mosquitos
undergo a metamorphosis sculpted in gold.
The buzzing body takes on a life of its own,
its usual role as menace lying far
beyond the margins of the screen.
The mosquito is beautiful,
a sentence I never expected to say, and
that I assume you never expected to hear.
Even the parts that are less elegant
become charming, like their legs.
They may look like a Christmas tree that’s
collapsed into a pile of Cheeto dust right now.
But when you think about the tiny hooks along
their surface that allow the mosquito to latch
onto surfaces, and of the scales that help
repel water so they can walk across ponds…
well, then you start to realize you’re looking at
an incredible feat of, you know, feet.
And of course, there are the wings,
which are always an impressive part
of nature to witness in action.
Along the edges, you can see scaly hairs that
the insect uses to process its surroundings.
Mosquito wings are unique in several ways.
They’re unusually long and narrow, and
they flap at an incredibly high rate,
even compared to other insects of their size,
around 800 times per second.
To learn how those wings work, scientists
needed to use high-speed cameras capturing
10,000 frames per second so they could
distinguish each step of that rapid movement.
And in the process of flying, the movement of the
wings creates the buzzing that
warns us a mosquito is nearby.
It’s an infuriating noise when it’s right against
your ear. But for the mosquitos, it’s a signal,
an instrument that guides them towards each other.
Male and female mosquitos will even
go so far as to converge on the same
wing-flapping frequency when they are courting.
And with that image in mind, we’ve conjured
up a vision of the mosquito that is both
beautiful and romantic, flirting
wistfully through wing flap patterns.
All it takes to shatter that notion is this part,
the proboscis.
This is what allows the mosquito to drink from us.
At first, the proboscis looks
like a simple instrument,
like a very poke-y straw that
connects with our blood vessels.
But in reality, it is a complex machine, made up
of six thin spear-like structures called stylets.
Two stylets hold the tissue apart while another
pair act like drill bits digging through our skin.
And then a stylet called the
labrum sniffs out blood
vessels using receptors that turn
our body’s chemistry into a map.
And when it does find the vessel, the
labrum converts itself into a pipeline,
carrying blood to the mosquito.
The sixth and last stylet helps the labrum with
its task by injecting mosquito
saliva into our blood vessels.
This is not just gross mosquito backwash.
Mosquito saliva contains enzymes that dilate our
blood vessels and prevent our
immune system from responding.
At least, that’s what the female mosquito does.
Because all of this work, it’s not actually
to provide the mosquito’s main meal.
Mosquitos sustain themselves
on nectar and fruit juices.
Blood, on the other hand, is about the next
generation, and the eggs that will make them.
So male mosquitos don’t consume blood.
Their proboscis isn’t even
strong enough to pierce our skin.
But female mosquitos need blood for
reproduction, using the nutrients—
particularly iron—
to fuel the growth of their eggs.
Over her lifetime, the female
mosquito may lay around 500 eggs.
So if the physical discomfort that follows a bite
is not enough misery for you, rest uneasily in the
knowledge that your blood has fueled the birth of
the next round of mosquitos that will plague you,
and the world.
And “plague” is the obvious word to
go with when it comes to mosquitos.
The Centers for Disease Control
and Prevention call mosquitos
“the World’s Deadliest Animal” because of the
essential role they play in spreading disease.
A shortlist of mosquito’s notorious
diseases includes malaria, dengue,
West Nile, Zika, and lymphatic filariasis.
The actual organisms responsible for these
diseases include protists, worms, and viruses.
But their spread is driven by mosquitos, hopping
from person to person to get their blood,
and leaving behind an unwanted memento
of the microcosmos when they leave.
Malaria, for example, is the potentially fatal
work of parasitic protists that
belong to the genus Plasmodium.
When an infected mosquito bites a human,
the plasmodium quickly travels to the liver,
usually reaching its destination in 20 minutes.
And then the parasite reproduces,
moving through different stages of their
life cycle as they infect red blood cells.
When another mosquito comes along
for blood, it will end up taking
some of the parasite with it, keeping
the cycle going and going and going.
In 2021, there were 247 million cases
of malaria worldwide, and 619,000
people died from the disease.
To try and prevent these deaths,
humans have tried many strategies to
curb the mosquito population or their ability to
spread disease. Insecticides, genetic engineering…
there have been a wide range of tools.
But we want to end with the one that
resonates most with the microcosmos.
It would look kind of like this, an array of
ciliates borne across the skin of a larva.
When scientists have pitted the vorticella—
a Journey to the Microcosmos favorite—
against the larvae of certain mosquito
species, the mosquitos have fared quite poorly.
It’s not clear why or how,
but the mosquito larvae die.
The vorticella might prevent them
from staying on the surface of water,
getting in the way of their respiration.
Or the vorticella might simply be poisoning the
mosquitos with chemical secretions of their own.
And if only the mosquito weren’t a
mosquito, perhaps we could sympathize.
Because we know the plight of
a pest attached to our skin,
leaving behind misfortunes both small and deadly.
But the microcosmos is the beginning and end of
so many journeys, and even the mighty mosquito—
the vector of so many diseases—
can find its own wanderings cut short .
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
We also want to say thank
you to all of those people
whose names you’re seeing on the screen right now.
Those are some of our Patreon patrons and we
could not continue to make this show without them.
If you’d like to see more from our
Master of Microscopes, James Weiss,
you can check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you’d like to see more from us, there
should be a subscribe button somewhere nearby.